yokanen walked from home to the bus stop
at an average speed of 5 kilometers per
hour he immediately got on his school
bus and traveled at an average speed of
60 kilometers per hour until he got to
school
the total distance from his home to
school is 35 kilometers and the entire
trip took one and a half hours
how many kilometers did joachim uncover
by walking and how many kilometers did
he cover by traveling on the bus it's
fascinating so i encourage you to pause
the video and try to think about it on
your own
alright so let's just define some
variables here how many kilometers did
he cover by walking let's call this
w and how many kilometers did he cover
by traveling on the bus let's call that
let's call that b
and so what do we know we know that the
kilometers and i actually can even draw
just to make sure that we're visualizing
this thing right so this right over here
is his home
that's his home and then he is going to
travel let's see they tell us
they tell us that it's 35 kilometers to
school so this is his school right over
here i'll draw a bigger building
that's his school and we know that this
distance is 35
35
kilometers we also know that it took one
and a half hours
one and a half hours and now he traveled
at different rates for different
distances so he traveled some distance
to
the school bus
so this is or to the bus stop
so that's the bus stop
right over there and we're seeing this
distance to the bus stop that's how much
he covered by walking
so this right over here this distance
right over here that is
w and then the rest of the distance he
covered by the bus
so the rest of this distance all of this
business right over there that is going
to be b
so what do we know we know the distance
covered by walking plus the distance
covered by bus is going to be 35
kilometers or 35 kilometers here this is
the entire
that is the entire distance from home
from home to school so we know that w
plus b
w
plus b
plus b
is equal to 35 kilometers
is equal to 35 kilometers
and just with one equation we're not
going to be able to figure out what w
and b are but we have another constraint
we know the total amount of time
so the total amount of time is going to
be one and a half hours so let me just
write that over here this is going to be
1.5 so what's the time traveled by
what's the time he walks let me write
this over here time
time
walking
well that's going to be the distance
walking divided by the rate walking so
the distance walking is w kilometers
w kilometers
divided by
his rate distance divided by your rate
is going to give you your time so let's
see his rate is five kilometers per hour
five kilometers per hour and so you're
gonna have kilometers cancel with
kilometers and if you divide by or if
you have one over hours in the
denominator that's going to be the same
thing this is going to be w over five
hours so the units work out so his time
walking is w over five w over five and
by that same logic his time on the bus
is going to be the distance on the bus
divided by
divided by the average speed of the
school bus so this is going to be 60.
this is all going to be in hours and now
we can solve this system of equations we
have two two linear equations with two
unknowns we should be able to find w and
b that satisfy both of these
now what's an easy thing to do let's see
if i can multiply this second equation
by negative
negative 5 then i'm going to this is
going to be a negative w here and so
it'll cancel out with this w up there so
let's do that so let's multiply the
second equation by and i'm just going to
switch to one color here so this top
equation is going to be w plus b
is equal to 35
this bottom equation if i multiply both
sides by negative five
so both sides by negative 5 so i'm going
to multiply both sides by negative 5.
i'm going to get negative 5 times w over
5 is negative w
negative 5 plus times b over 60 let's
see it's going to be negative 5 over 60
that's negative 112 so because it's
negative b
over 12 and then is going to be equal to
1.5 times negative 5 is negative 7.5
negative 7.5 now we can just add the
left and right hand sides of these two
equations and let me i could do this a
little bit neater let me
actually delete
let me make these line up a little bit
better so let me delete that
make this so this this first equation
was
whoops
this first equation
was
w
plus b
is equal to 35. now they line up better
and now i can add the left side sides of
these equations and the right hand sides
so the left-hand sides the w's cancel
out that's what we wanted now b minus b
over 12 or b minus the 12th of b well
that's going to be 11 12 b 11
12 b
is equal to
let's see 35
minus
7.5
see 35 minus 7 would be 28 and then
another half this would be 27.5
27.5 and since i'm dealing with a
fraction here let me write this as a
fraction so this is the same thing as 55
over
2
yep so let me just write it this way
this is the same thing as 55
over 2. now to solve for b i just have
to multiply both sides times this
reciprocal i'll switch colors just to
ease the monotony so multiply both sides
by 12 over 11
12 over 11. what we get these cancel out
what we get is that b
so i'll do this in this color
b
is equal to let's see i have a 12 in the
numerator 2 in the denominator so i can
make that a 6
and a 1. and then i have a 55 and 11. i
could divide both by 11. so it's going
to be 5
and a 1. so it's 5 times 6 b is equal to
30 and b was in kilometers so he travels
30 kilometers
30 kilometers by bus
b is equal to 30 kilometers and the
amount that he walks well we can figure
that out if this is 30 well the amount
that he walks is going to be 5.
this is going to be five kilometers
w let me write this w is equal to five
kilometers he walks five kilometers and
he goes by the bus 30 kilometers